Welcome to "Ear Biscuits"
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we are doing what we've done
for the past couple of years,
which is give our top
10 moments of the year.
Yes.
I've been looking forward to this.
We each have 10, so there's 20 total.
I'm a fan of nostalgia, even
if it's short-term nostalgia.
I think just looking back at 12 months,
when it comes to nostalgia,
you gotta say, that's
pretty short term, right?
I don't consider it nostalgic.
I like the process of looking back,
I look back through my photos.
You saw me doing this yesterday.
I look back through my calendar.
I look back through my
digital journal and thoughts.
I don't really call it a journal.
I just like-
Diary, you call it a little diary.
No, I have notes
Little diary.
on my computer,
and I just have one note
that's called Thoughts,
and sometimes I date it, so
it's basically a journal.
I just don't have the
guts to call it a journal
because I'll just feel guilty
for not actually keeping up with it.
So, I just call it Thoughts.
I got a journal that I don't
keep up with.
I mean, just make a journal
entry every once in a while.
Just because you don't feel
guilty about something-
Don't make me feel guilty about it.
Oh .
I'm saying I got a whole
folder in my Evernote.
Are you using Evernote?
Okay, I'll say it. I use an Evernote.
And I got a list of 10 things.
Yeah.
I don't wanna sit here
and talk about Evernote when
we got some amazing things
that have happened to
us in an amazing year.
Well, hasn't this been a great year?
2020, unlike any other.
I gotta tell you, honestly,
in previous years,
I have had difficulty narrowing it down
to my top 10 moments.
Yeah.
I had trouble coming up with 10.
Listen, I mean,
it has been a good year for
us, relative to a lot of folks,
but this has been a tough
year for a lot of people.
Some of the things that
made the list, it was like,
I think it's, they made
the list given the year,
given the state of 2020.
Definitely.
It's like, oh, normally you wouldn't think
that that would make the list, but boy ,
with a year like this
year, it's a highlight.
I know we call it the top 10, but it's...
I've thought of it as like
top 10 most impactful moments
or
So, you changed
the theme this year.
memories.
You changed it from the last two years.
No.
I mean, it's milestone moments.
Yeah, if there's something
They're not all
as big and impactful, yeah.
enjoyable.
Right.
I focus on the positive personally
just because I felt like
it was a negative year.
So, there may be some things
that didn't make the list
that seemed monumental
that I just was like,
oh, I ain't putting on my list.
No, this is definitely a positive list
that I've worked up as well.
But I mean, there's some...
Well, how do I put it?
There's been some valleys
of darkness in this year,
and I just wanted to acknowledge that
in some of what I put in here,
but it's mostly silver lining.
Okay.
It's mostly silver lining.
So, we're just gonna alternate-
It's not true that clouds have a...
If clouds have a silver lining,
that's like an environmental problem.
That means there's like silver dioxide
or something that somehow if
there's some mining process
got into the cloud,
that you don't wanna be breathing that in.
I think the problem is yours.
Being that you can't even
find the silver lining
in the term the silver lining.
In a silver lining.
Silver lining is a problematic analogy.
It's a sun behind the cloud.
And I think about silver being
in the content of the cloud
And I'll let you know-
having silver in it.
I didn't think I needed to explain this.
A silver lining lets that there
is a sun behind the cloud.
It's a bright spot that
you just have to trust
is gonna come out again
and make you a warm
and happy and better in 2021.
If you drink too much colloidal silver,
it can make you blue.
I think there was a guy
that was on like Donahue
back in the '90s
that turned blue.
Are you stalling?
Are you afraid to celebrate
No. No.
your year?
No, I'll go first
as a matter of fact.
We do need to get started
because I mean there's
20 things on this list,
there's no reason to talk
about silver linings.
Join us, #EarBiscuits,
let us know what what your
milestone moments of 2020 are.
But go first.
Number 10 for me is a
moment that I talked about,
the vacation that we took
to San Diego with my family.
And there was the moment
that I got to surf for the
first time with both of my boys.
Locke and Shepherd, Shepherd's
first time ever surfing.
And there was just a
moment that we're out there
and I'm like, I mean,
nobody's really killing it,
nobody's really ripping it,
no one's doing anything that
they would write home about
or are going to be videoed.
But there were dolphins, I remember.
No, that was a different time.
Oh.
The dolphins swimming alongside me
is I think the highlight of my life.
And that was not this year,
it was some other year.
But I lobbed that at you as an opportunity
I'm sure there were dolphins
to revision history yet.
Well, there were dolphins
probably in our midst.
Also something I learned that
week while we were surfing,
is that there was, this year especially,
an unusually high number of
juvenile great white sharks
that are swimming amongst
the swimmers and surfers
all along the California coast.
Can we just take the
words, juvenile and great,
and just replace them both with one word?
They cancel each other out, white sharks.
Yeah.
Fledgling white sharks.
But it turns out
that these juvenile great white sharks
are not aggressive towards humans usually.
So anyway.
But anyway, having this
moment with my kids
doing something that I felt like,
I talked about pushing
Shepherd and catching a wave,
and then there was the
next day that we went out,
all three of us surfing together.
It's a special moment doing
one of my favorite things
with two of my favorite people.
Number 10
for me.
My number-
Oh, we're already to my number 10.
Yeah, I mean, with COVID hitting,
I don't know if you remember
COVID hit this year.
Yeah, kinda hitting.
'Cause people are saying that it was here
in December of 2019.
They're really starting
to figure that out now.
Right, right, right, right.
But .
We can't not talk about
COVID in this thing,
but one big silver lining,
once we really started to hunker down,
this is not one of my moments,
but I remember we talked about it,
just like watching the news
and processing in real-time
with the rest of the world,
trying to make sense of
what is beginning to happen,
and news anchors saying,
"Get ready, this is your new normal."
And as much as I was trying to process it,
you just kinda have to live it.
And so, as it starts to sink in,
oh man, this has been a month,
this has been two months,
I remember when we would count
how many weeks we had been
without going out or being
in contact with people
or each other.
And it was in that context
that my number 10 happened.
Which is, we instituted a weekly Zoom call
with our college friends.
Ah, yes.
Thanksgiving of 2019, when I went home
I reconnected with a couple
of the guys in person
and I gave a teaser to some things
we were gonna be talking
about on "Ear Biscuits",
which I'm sure, with
the live series podcast,
which I'm sure we'll talk
more about in a little bit,
and just kinda reconnecting,
letting them know where we were at
and how we were gonna go
public with this type of stuff.
And then we started a text group
as those podcasts came out,
but then it turned into a Zoom chat,
that everybody didn't make it every week,
but especially at certain
key points for me,
it was a big deal to be able
to reconnect with friends,
just laugh and reminisce
and talk about how we're
processing this thing.
Right.
And know
that you've got someone
that we knew so well
and then reconnecting,
it was like picking up
right where we left off
with those guys.
You got Greg, our college roommate,
Tim, who was the second college roommate
who moved in with us.
You got a Ham, who came along with Nukirk,
there was the sister
apartment that they lived in
that we would connect
with and hang out with
and got into all types of trouble.
That's the apartment that we were in
when we made the decision
to drop the poop off at the party,
we've never even talked about.
Right.
It was therapeutic, and it is therapeutic
to keep that friendship going.
Especially when there was
a time where it's like,
there wasn't a lot to look
forward to in the week,
and we really needed
that level of connection.
And now we've revived the friendship
to a point that it's
something that we cherish,
and it's active.
I wonder how many people
reconnected in that way this year.
I have to believe that.
I mean, I know that there's a thing
where people are reconnecting with friends
that they used to see in person.
Like, hey, let's have a cocktail hour.
Or let's have a little-
On Zoom.
Let's have a dinner party on Zoom.
We should've done a little bit of that,
but yeah, connecting,
it's funny because we...
And I also hung out with
a couple of the guys,
we went to NAC State basketball
game when I went back.
For Christmas.
Yup.
Nukirk and Ham and I
met and went to a game.
And so, we would see each
other in that capacity.
But yeah, it's funny how
we were talking just the other day
'cause we still have a lot
of meetings all the time,
just in the professional sense,
and a couple of the meetings
that were gonna be Zoom calls
ended up being scheduled as phone calls.
And then it just felt so strange
to just be on a conference
call where people were like,
"Hold on, wait, let's do
this as a video call."
I actually got angry inside
that I couldn't see the
people that I was talking to.
It was like, "What? Are we in 2019?"
It's amazing how quickly,
I almost felt like I
can't have a conversation
with just someone's voice,
within the span of one
year, less than a year,
all of a sudden the capacity
to just talk to somebody on the phone
without seeing their face,
it's amazing how this is
just a cultural revolution.
But I think it was like, oh,
I'm talking to my coworkers,
employees, business partners
through this medium,
why can't I do that with all friends?
Why can't I do that with...
I mean, they were all spread
out across the country.
We got North Carolina,
Missouri, we got Washington,
we got Japan,
we all hop on the call and
It really gave a sense
of connectedness.
Connect.
I mean, it's one thing
to talk to your family,
but the way that you can, at least for me,
the way that I'm able to open
up with that friend group
and kinda process, and it
be this trusted environment
where it's like, we're just friends.
You can have that with
different family members,
I don't have that.
So, it was nice to have that,
and also to kinda track their experience
with where they are physically
in the world because
Every state is a little bit different.
it didn't matter if you were Nukirk
over there in Japan,
or if you were in Missouri or here.
There was a shared experience that...
But it was a little bit different.
And you started to put your
finger on the pulse of like,
how things really are back at home,
and really assessing that.
So, I mean, it was connecting
on a relational sense
but also in like
a socio global sense.
Socio global.
So, that's my number 10.
Okay.
My number nine is,
this is gonna get a little bit cryptic
because I'm gonna tell you something
but not tell you fully what it was.
And relatively recently,
I'd say in the past month.
Do I get credit for this?
Do you get credit for it?
Yeah. I had to remind you of this.
Oh, I thought,
do you get credit
No.
for adding the idea to the list?
Reminding you that it should be
on your list, yeah.
No.
No, you didn't because that's another one.
That's also gonna be cryptic.
Oh, dang, you got a
bunch of cryptic stuff.
I got two cryptic things
on the list.
Okay. All right.
So, what is this?
This is where you and I...
Now, I mean, this is a twofer
because I'm also gonna talk
about the creative house.
This was a year of the creative house
which has been a godsend for us.
Having a place that we could go
that is not our homes and not our office.
It's a homey office.
I believe we moved in in February.
That makes sense.
Maybe late January.
And so, the timing was just serendipitous
that it happened to work
out in the year of COVID
that we had this place that we could go.
And we've had some good
solid creative time there.
And relatively recently,
we spent an afternoon
conceptualizing an idea for a movie
that we would like to make.
You know this, we always got things
that we were trying to do.
We got things we're trying
to get off the ground.
Yeah.
And we spent, I don't
know how long it was.
I mean, it took us about an
hour to no more than two hours
with this full discussion
of kinda unpacking...
Boy, if this movie gets made...
Then we'll have to release the recording
of us coming up with the ,
'cause we did record it.
Yeah.
The idea has shifted a little bit,
but sure, we can release it.
It is
You know it's a good idea
potentially the most-
when you're like,
hold on, let's record this conversation.
Just audio.
Man, you also know
it's a good idea when
the next day you're like
You sleep on it.
is this idea too crazy?
Yes.
Is this idea too crazy for us to do?
Yes, but let's do it anyway.
Right, and I think that's
kinda where we're at.
So anyway, we-
Can't do it alone now
and you can't guarantee
that it will ever get done.
But even that feeling,
it's not on my list but it should be.
I mean, we're moving forward,
we keep talking about it.
We're adding some meat to those bones.
The busier that we've gotten,
in spite of, how do I say this?
We haven't traveled because of COVID,
we haven't toured, we haven't
done a lot of the things
that would normally really
make our schedule super packed,
super busy.
What things that made 2019 an
extraordinarily packed year.
Right.
There was so much
travel, a lot of touring.
But you would think that
we would have replaced
all that time with all this
unfettered, creative time.
And really what it's been replaced with is
Struggle.
just trying to maintain a business
and a show in the midst
of all the turmoil.
Yeah, trying to keep
Keep it a flow.
what's going going.
And it has taken more of our time
than I think we ever anticipated, but-
And it took a huge emotional toll
because there was this
pervasive undercurrent
of emotion and anxiety that was like,
are we doing enough to preserve?
And we discussed this.
I mean, if you go back through
the podcast of this year,
I think it was something
that was just always there
beneath the surface when
we weren't discussing it.
And that was,
we were constantly reacting to news
and requirements and
guidelines and restrictions
and just feeling the
weight of making decisions,
not only for us and our families,
but for all of our employees.
It was a lot, man.
And yeah, and then you add on,
I feel like we should be
able to capitalize on this
and be more creative.
We should write a whole screenplay
or this, that, and the other.
And we have been.
And so, that was
part of the struggle.
Yeah.
And we have been...
And again, another one
of my items on the list
will allude to this,
but we have been able to
conceptualize some things
that we're excited about.
But there was something about the nature
of the way that this
particular idea was birthed,
and there was just this
reckless abandon and commitment
to just like, let's just follow
this and not judge ourselves
or the idea as it's happening,
we'll do that tomorrow.
And it was just, again,
it was an unfettered creative exercise
that led to what could be,
we've had a lot of dumb ideas,
what could be one of our stupider ideas
but hopefully stupid in a smart way.
And hopefully something
that will get made.
However many months or years from now,
we'll be like, hey, yeah, we made that.
We made that movie, man.
I think, yeah, that brainstorming session,
it really represents the,
not culmination, but kinda like the,
what's the word I'm looking for?
It's like the payoff,
the realization of the
vision of running this
The creative house.
creative house.
Yeah.
That it was a place where
we could go and isolate
and not worry about being interrupted
and just unabashedly
just come up with stuff.
It was fun.
So much of what we do now in
terms of our creative work
is compartmentalized,
literally on a calendar.
This is when you've gotta start,
and this is when you gotta stop.
And even if you don't start
when you need to start,
this is when you need to stop
because there's something right after it
that you gotta move on to.
And it pressurizes things in a way that
that pressure can lead to frustration
when you have to move away from it,
or it's just not going well
or nothing comes from it.
But to give ourselves permission
and the physical space
to just have a pure creative conversation
and that be the objective.
And then for something crazy and beautiful
and potentially career melding,
to come out of it, I mean,
I would say is just a bonus.
Because the experience itself was worthy
of being in anybody's top 10 list.
Did it make yours?
No.
Okay. Well, all right.
So, go ahead and pitch the idea.
No.
Tell them what the movie is about.
I'm not going to.
Tell them who stars in it.
I'm not gonna say anything.
I mean, just give them one word.
Give them one word so
that when it comes back,
when they start to hear
about it, if it ever happens,
they'll remember it,
they'll have confirmation
that that thing was this thing.
A guy.
No.
Okay, that's a guy.
A guy wakes up.
Okay, all right. All right, that'll work.
I don't think that part will change.
Yeah.
It could though.
All right. So, I'm gonna
go to my number nine.
Man, this is gonna take a while,
but I promise it's gonna be worth it.
And if it's not just stop listening.
Some of them are, I'm pretty sure.
But the way that we've structured this,
is that we're counting up.
Which implies that the moments
get more meaningful to us
as we go.
So, even if you don't like
what we've talked about so far,
chances are, they increase as we go on.
That's weird.
But first, let's promote some merch.
Oh, you wanna do that.
We got these mythic cups.
If you pour cold water into
them, they change color.
This one turned purple.
Only where
the cold water touches.
This one's purple, and
this one turns blue.
That one turns red and
that one turns purple.
'Cause we both have a blue one.
Wouldn't it be cool if you
poured something coal in it
and it just incinerated.
That's a 2021 idea.
We gotta get rid of this stock.
I think that that's just making something
out of like rice paper or
some disintegrating cups that-
You pour water on something and it burns.
Oh, and it burns.
And to find out
how to burn water,
mythical.com.
Get yourself something to drink out of.
These are nestable,
they're stackable, here.
Nest those other two, man, come on.
Look at that.
You could probably stack
them 100 high if you want.
This right here, these four cups,
which they come in a set of four.
But don't wash them like that.
Don't wash them.
'Cause only one of them
will get clean.
Don't wash them like that.
Mythical.com got
everything you would need.
Spend that Christmas money.
Okay. Number nine
My number nine is something that...
Are you looking at my list?
Don't look over my list,
listen to what I'm saying.
I can't help it.
Why? You're like cheating at my list.
You want me to say what it is?
No.
Okay.
It's kind of my thing
to say what my thing is.
Well, I, wasn't gonna say
it, I was just looking at it.
Now you can interject and say,
now, do I get credit for this?
It's like when
That's cool.
you accidentally can't turn
the subtitles off to a movie.
You can't help, but read them.
Yeah. I hate that.
You're like, oh, man, I
totally understand everything
that they're saying, but
I have to read it as well.
The one...
I wouldn't say the one,
I would say this is the
preeminent constant of COVID
for the Neal family.
I mean, and we never talked about it.
We never talked about setting
a rule or an expectation
that this is the one thing
that we as a family are gonna fixate on
and is gonna align us.
It is gonna create
a family meeting.
It's gonna create something
where we will come together
and everyone will be motivated
to be in the same room
with everybody else, every single night.
Hold on, you do it every night?
Week night, even weekends.
The conversation we have to have is,
not are we gonna come
together to fixate on this,
but we have to have conversations
when we're not going to.
Heads up, I've got something.
So, we're not gonna be
able to all get together
for this thing that is the life force
of the Neal family in COVID.
I didn't realize
you did it that often.
Say what it is.
"Survivor", the television show.
Reality competition show,
I don't know if you've heard of it.
Two years ago, at the end of
2018, we went on a Sedona trip.
I'm sure I talked about it
at the beginning of 2019.
And I remember talking about
how we started watching.
So, that's when we started.
We watched "Millennials vs Gen X",
and then we were like hooked on it.
And then I was like, we're
gonna keep watching "Survivor",
and we never did.
We never went back to it.
And then I just remembered,
we had so much fun watching "Survivor",
we're gonna start watching.
I'm sure I talked about this
There's a lot to watch.
whenever we did the podcast from home,
I told you at that time that
we started watching "Survivor".
Well, let me tell you now,
we are still watching "Survivor".
How many seasons have you
gone through this year?
We went back and we started
with, I think season...
I did some research on,
if we're gonna binge watch
but skip the most boring ones.
Yeah.
You started watching
the most recent episode
The most recent season.
which is like an all-star season
with like winners and
stuff and fan favorites
or whatever it is.
Where's the winners.
And I said,
I know how the Neals are-
It spoiled all the seasons.
Yeah, it spoiled all the seasons.
But I'm not gonna sit with my family
and watch every season.
So, it's okay.
And I was like,
listen, I know that's gonna
work for the McLaughlins,
but for the Neals, I know how we are.
If I can get the family
rehooked on "Survivor",
then it can be our thing for COVID.
And again, I said, I think
this may be the case,
I wanna do some research.
And then I said, we're
gonna start with season,
I think is 17, it may be 19,
the first HD season.
And then we started watching through,
skipping the ones that
the consensus said sucked.
And then we got to a
certain point and we said,
we're even gonna watch the ones that suck
because we're such a fan of "Survivor" now
that we're just gonna watch them all.
'Cause I don't wanna run out.
Are you gonna go SD all the way?
Are you gonna go to SD?
No, we're still moving forward in time.
You're not going back
to standard definition.
Standard definition's for suckers.
That would be that.
That'd be a difficult move.
It'd be worse than a phone call.
You can't see anything.
If we have to do it,
we'll do it.
But we've watched "Survivor"
since that point in quarantine until now.
Again, it is our default expectation
that we are going to watch
it every single night.
And so-
So, do you like Jeff
Probst more or less now?
Oh, more.
I would love to meet him.
You can't get enough Probst?
I can't get enough of this guy.
I think he's great.
I feel like I know him.
I love the show,
it has something for
everybody in our family.
It aligns us.
It's a powerful force
and it's a great show.
And your teenagers have
not tried to stop this.
Lilly and Lincoln love it too, yeah.
My family had a great time watching
You said-
last season.
But if we try to do it every night,
that would cause problems for us.
That's my number nine.
And I'm gonna keep going.
I'm not really gonna hit rock bottom,
unless, for some reason,
like come halfway through
2021, we run out of "Survivor".
And then we're somehow
still locked down.
You're saying,
when your life turns back to normal,
which will happen sometime in 2021.
We won't keep watching "Survivor"
every single night as a family.
No, 'cause that'd be like,
kids won't be gonna school.
Yeah, they'll have life.
Yeah.
And my daughter hopefully
will go off to college.
Maybe she'll stick around for "Survivor".
Can't argue with that.
You gotta think
about the effect you're
having on these kids.
Number eight.
I alluded to this in
the episode we recorded
about all the purchases
we've made on Amazon.
Cooking for me, is a general highlight.
I'll zero in, or home in, or even hone in
on one particular moment.
But I think cooking has been a...
Home cooking, I'm sure-
Hone cooking?
Home cooking has been a big part
of a lot of people's
lives this year, right?
You're not going out
to, well, some of you,
if you're like us, not
going out to restaurants,
doing a lot of takeout, maybe,
but I think that there's
only so much takeout
that you can do or afford.
And so, a lot of people are like,
"Well, I'm gonna figure
out how to cook myself."
And we finally finished the outdoor area.
I've got my little grill
smoker area out there
that was featured in an episode
of "Fancy Fast Food" with Josh.
Mythical chef, Josh.
And I am really enjoying.
I go out there, I play music and I cook.
I mean, over Thanksgiving, I-
You cook in the house too, though.
I cook in the house,
but there's just something
about that outdoor area.
I brined and injected and smoked
a turkey over Thanksgiving.
I also deep fried two .
I think, the one for Mike-
Well, that said,
that was a good .
The one for Mike and Jenny
turned out to not be nearly as dry
by the way, I got a report on that.
But anyway, has so much joy making that.
And then-
Is that your claim to fame?
That's your thing?
You said you were homing in on one thing.
You're talking about the turkey.
No, no, no, no.
The thing I think is the bigger highlight
was when I was able to cook those,
the Nashville hot chicken
sandwiches for your family.
Oh yeah.
And my family.
I was there for that.
I think that's the best tasting thing
that I've ever personally made.
I've made some good tasting things.
I'll vouch for that.
But there's something, and if
you cook on a regular basis,
you can relate to this.
My mother-in-law used
to say this all the time
and I never understood.
She's an incredible cook.
And we would sit down to eat
and I'd be like, "This is so good."
And she'd be like,
"It's not that good if you've
been cooking it all day."
And I was like, that's interesting.
I have found that to be the case,
that if you spend all
this time with this thing
and then you serve it,
a lot of times it's not as satisfying
if it's somebody else did
it and gave it to you.
I don't understand it.
You can
onto it.
I don't understand the psychology of that.
So, usually, even if something
is really good to other people,
I'll be a little bit disappointed in it.
Those Nashville hot chicken sandwiches
that I pickle brined the
thighs for like six hours,
deep fried them in peanut oil,
served them on Hawaiian buns
with a little bit of comeback
sauce and some dill pickles.
It's the best thing I've ever made.
And I had so much joy making
it and so much joy serving it.
That you tricked yourself into eating it
as if you didn't make it.
No, I'm saying it was so good
that it overcame that
psychological barrier.
If you do say so yourself.
No, I do say so myself.
Well, you can. I was
there, hey, it was good.
I mean, I'm not gonna take
credit for it, it was a recipe.
People who get really excited
about being able to follow a recipe,
is like somebody following
directions to a town
and being like, "Hey, look at what I did."
I invented the town.
Right, you didn't invent the town,
you just followed directions to get there.
You're not the mayor
because you took MapQuest.
You know what I'm saying?
So, what are you doing?
So, what I'm saying is that,
I have discovered the joy of cooking.
MapQuest.
Isn't that a book
by Julia Child?
No, it's a website like Google Maps
but people don't use it
as much anymore.
The joy of cooking.
MapQuest.
That's what
I'm talking about.
So yeah, the joy of cooking in 2020,
it's one of my highlights.
In fact, number eight.
I almost skipped to number four for time.
Just kidding.
Okay.
What number am I?
I'm on number-
Eight.
Okay, I'm after you.
And what you said reminded me,
I mean, a milestone, again not on my list,
we launched the Mythical Kitchen channel
at the top of this year.
Yeah, we did.
And I'm super proud of those
people making it happen.
Yeah, speaking of the joy of cooking.
Josh, even Nicole and Trevor over there.
Even Nicole and Trevor.
No, they're doing great stuff.
My number eight is,
we launched our vlogs.
Now, they went away and
I run the risk of...
Disappointing.
Yeah, just bringing up the-
Opening a wound?
Opening a wound that
we made an announcement
towards the end from our handheld phones,
filmed in separate locations,
you at your home, me in my home saying,
"Hey, you know what?
This has gotten away from
what we wanted to do,
what we wanted this to be.
And yeah, we haven't gone back to it."
But it was a special
era to make those vlogs.
A few that stand out for me,
finding the rat in the attic.
I'm super proud of you
taking a shower at my house.
You helping me find
Yeah, I'm proud of that too.
a rat at my house,
and us going off-roading with Shepherd.
One of the last ones that we filmed
before we went into quarantine.
And then we started
trying to do things every week separately.
And we were under a lot of pressure.
Yeah.
We lost the joy of it.
It wasn't the outlet it was
supposed to be because it was,
oh my gosh, what are we gonna do now?
And it's not really about
what we wanna do together.
It's about what we can do to make do.
And that's not what this was about.
I'm glad we stopped doing it,
and we reserve the right
to pick it up and do it
whenever we wanna do it, and
release something over there.
And I'm sure we'll do that.
But I look back on those videos,
especially those that I've mentioned,
like the skin walls one did really well.
But it was a little different
than the other ones,
but I look back on that really fondly.
I do as well.
I don't know exactly why I
didn't put it on my list,
and I think that I have a little bit of...
I associate some negative energy with that
because I know how the
folks who really liked it
feel about the fact that
we did it and then stopped.
And so, yeah, I do feel, I don't know,
maybe shame is the word.
But I like that you're
seeing it for what it was
and how special it was
as it was happening.
And like you said, I'll
go ahead and tell you,
we already filmed one.
We haven't finished filming it,
but there is gonna be
at least another one.
I don't know when it's gonna come out.
But, in fact, we've
got a cart in our inbox
that we need to review.
That's right. That's right.
So, there is gonna be
at least another one,
it's just, how regular is
it gonna be, I don't know.
I'm filming another one too.
And you've got one that
you've been working on.
Yeah.
Something else that didn't
make the list is that like,
well, it reminds me, I...
An honorable mention was,
there is a furry addition
to the Neal household.
Yeah, that happened.
Of the feline variety.
And I've been holding back a lot there.
Right, but we're gonna-
Including putting in my top 10.
But we're gonna put it,
we're gonna let it loose on them.
That's the plan.
Even saying this, I hope will help me
follow through with that.
Yeah, I feel like
And you know what?
committing to it.
'Cause we filmed the
couple like we had the idea
whenever we were focused
on doing original TikToks.
Yeah, we filmed some stuff.
Once we started getting back together
and we were trying our hand at that,
we decided to document that.
I hate that I'm saying this
'cause it's just gonna frustrate people,
but there's a decent amount
of footage associated with us,
we started documenting the
process of figuring out TikTok
and then that fills it out.
I mean, just because we
reallocated ourselves
to other things and-
Sometimes we squeeze our
tubes a little too hard.
We squeeze too hard.
Us being the tubes.
Yeah.
And you will hear about,
in fact, my next one,
you'll understand maybe some other places
that the tube was getting squeezed.
Oh my goodness.
So, that's just the thing,
to me, one of the themes of our
experience this year is just
trying to figure out what it
is we need to be investing in.
Yeah.
Investing our time in.
Creatively, business-wise, personally,
and just trying to balance
and maintain some sort of
semblance of personal wellbeing.
And not really being able to quantify
how much effort and time and care
we needed to allocate to
ourselves and our families
in order to hold things together,
internally and externally.
It was the thing that we talked about,
but it turns out, you couldn't
have talked about it enough.
And I think that that's, with
the things that we did do,
it was always running parallel
with this assessment of,
is this the right thing to do?
Because so much was up in
the air and changing so much.
Well, I can use that as a
segue into my number seven.
Because I feel like the reason
we started doing the vlogs was,
we're always on things.
There's very few idle moments
in the business day for us.
And we talked before about
all the things that we work on
that don't see the light of day
because they're not just things
that we make for YouTube,
they're things that involve
working with other people,
developing things, gatekeepers,
more traditional media stuff.
And I think that after
many years of doing that,
there was a little bit
of frustration that like,
man, everybody moves so slow
and it's hard to convince
people to let us make things,
and let's do something else on YouTube.
And I think that the vlogs kinda came out
of a little bit of creative frustration,
but then COVID really complicated it
and made it difficult for
us to even be together.
And then it was around the
same time we were realizing
that this is becoming an
obligation, a weekly obligation.
And it's also like,
well, we still wanna do
other creative things,
and again, there's only so
much toothpaste in the tube.
So, there was a confluence
of factors that led to that,
but one of them is a real positive thing.
And again, I'm gonna be cryptic again.
But...
I cannot take credit for this one?
You can take credit for adding
this one to the list, yes.
Because
To your list.
I did not have it on my list.
And I don't remember when
this process started,
but I believe it started in 2019.
Yeah.
That we became friends with a person
who has a rather storied
television career,
creating some iconic television shows,
and someone whose television
shows that they have created,
there's very little crossover
with anything that fits
our sensibility or tone.
And you would be like,
huh, that's interesting.
That's not anything like I've
seen Rhett and Link create,
but we decided,
wouldn't it be fun and weird
and strange and exciting
to work together to create
a show that is like,
where does the world
of this person's ideas
meet the world of Rhett and Link's ideas.
And by show, you mean television show.
Television show.
Yeah.
And so, we have developed
a television show.
We have developed the world-
Yeah, we had Zoom calls
where we would just...
Well, I don't remember how it started.
What was the nugget of an idea...
It was, what if we did something
to collaborate together
and...
We had a nugget of an idea
and we kinda pitched it his way, right?
I can't remember, don't matter.
I don't remember exactly
how that the initial ball got rolling,
but I do remember he sent over
like a couple paragraphs of a writeup
that was like an initial idea.
Then we kinda took that
and put our spin on it.
And then it became this totally...
I mean, whether or not this becomes
a television show or not,
which we will be trying very hard in 2021
to get people to make the show,
it has been one hell of a
process, and very, very fun.
The world that we have
created is very deep
and strange and funny.
And the thing that has been a joy for me
has been being able to
work with this person
who has so much experience
and specific skill
in the area of writing
and creating television.
We took a stab at writing the pilot,
and we kind of go on
instinct and some experience,
and also, it's not like we don't read
about the process of
what makes good writing,
but there's just something
about being able to hand
something over to this guy
and get his insights
and notes on something.
I felt like I went to school
this year in a real good way,
and learned a whole lot
about the writing process.
Yeah, and we have a pilot to show for it.
Literally just-
Well, we have a script
for a pilot, never made it yet.
That's right, yeah.
We have a pilot script to show for it.
But yeah, it was a cool
experience, not only getting notes
but like to get audio notes
that were like kind of a
stream of consciousness,
kind of like, oh, this
is how he approaches it,
this is how he thinks about it,
and this is what needs to change.
It was a thrill.
And since you're much more of a writer,
that's why I was like, this
needs to be on your list.
Yeah, it was.
This has been a big chunk of my time.
We both have put a lot of time into it.
When you ask the question of like,
what do Rhett and Link do all the time?
Well, one of the things is
we work on stuff like this.
The conclusion I've come
to about this one is,
and I've been thinking about this
with some of our other
things that we've developed,
like we wrote a pilot for a
show about musical therapy,
seven or eight years ago, right,
when we were trying to make our first go
at like Hollywood,
besides commercial gangs?
Yeah.
And we wrote the, we've got that pilot.
I don't know, it's probably not any good.
We should dig that up.
But digging that up and
doing a some kind of reading
or something,
Yeah, that's a good idea.
I think maybe put it on a society,
that would be a good
thing for the society.
Yeah, we'll figure it out.
But the stuff that-
Legitimate,
that's what we call it.
Right. The town
The name of the town
was legitimate.
was called legitimate,
but it obviously had a double meaning.
Yeah.
But this idea, the movie idea,
again, these things
would probably never see
the light of day, but I'm
believing that both of them will.
And hoping that both of them will.
Who is the guy?
You're gonna tell the
people who the guy is?
Nope. I'm not.
And I'm a little fuzzy on why
we can't but it's just like,
you gotta keep the lid on these things,
and I understand that,
so I'm sorry if you're frustrated.
They're not frustrated, this is a tease.
It just gives us something
to look forward to
when we are able to announce it.
My number seven
is the Jimmy Fallon hug.
Whenever we had to move our
production to our homes,
we were like, of course,
we're gonna do this.
And this is an opportunity.
And a lot of this podcast for those weeks,
I think, we would unpack the
discovery that this is tough.
This is demanding.
This is more demanding
than we anticipated.
This is exhausting.
This is frustrating.
Not fun .
There were fun points.
But I remember getting up the morning
that we were gonna be on the tonight show
without leaving our respective homes.
We were gonna institute the split screen
that we're employing for GMM,
and we were gonna make a
three-way split screen.
And then we had this idea
to bring in arms and get
Jimmy to be in the middle
and then give us a hug.
And Jessie's arm came over your shoulder
and Lilly's arm came over my shoulder
and it seemed like it worked.
It seemed like Jimmy had really short arms
and feminine hands,
giving us a hug.
But I remember getting up that morning
and it wasn't the only
thing we had to shoot,
but there's a different
type of nervousness
with being on the tonight show
when you're in charge of the
all the technical side of it
from your own home.
But we had slotted to
shoot our carpool vlog
that we do every month
for the Mythical Society.
A 20 minute, basically
unedited, us driving in a car,
but we had to figure that out.
We were sitting in separate cars
filming it in a split screen
in each of our driveways,
and I was so keyed up
about being on Fallon
and frustrated about having to process
all this additional things
that I just didn't feel like
it fit in my brain.
And I kind of felt like
I could burst into tears
in .
I felt like that a few times this year.
And that carpool vlog became
the most raw and honest,
not in an "Ear Biscuits" kind of way,
but in like a, hey, we're
about to be on Fallon.
What are we gonna wear?
Oh yeah, I remember this.
Remember that?
Yeah.
It that it just became
a very like,
we're having a conversation
that we just needed to have.
And we were making
content at the same time.
And it was like, we were
gearing up for this thing
and processing how it felt to get ready
to be on the tonight show.
I'm glad we have that documented.
Because to me, that was
the professional feeling
of quarantine.
What was captured in that carpool vlog.
But then the payoff was
this thing that we got to...
I mean, one of the highlights 2019
was like wrapping the first
song that we ever wrote
while playing with the
roots on the tonight show
the year before.
And then a year later,
Jimmy's at his house,
we're at our homes, it
was just so surreal.
There's so many moments this year of like,
especially as it was unpacking itself,
it's like, this can't really be happening.
It's like, I've never
experienced in something
that so consistently felt like a dream.
Or a nightmare.
And oscillated between
the two very frequently.
So, the Fallon hug is like
the beautiful silver lining
that to me, represents
everything production
that we put ourselves through.
I'm glad you put it on your list.
Again, I did-
I think, we have
a shared list.
I think we just have a top 20.
Yeah, well, but I'm just saying
that the reason that I didn't again is,
that period of time was so frustrating.
And the Fallon thing was
one of the highlights,
but making the show at home,
what seemed sweet and
endearing for a few episodes
became a real frustration
in a chore, in a lot of ways.
And for whatever reason,
just very few people,
like lot less people watched it.
I think it just was a different
thing, we're not together.
But I'm glad it's on your list.
Number six for me, this isn't something
that my wife and I discovered
for the first time,
but it is something that we connected over
maybe in a new way.
Oh, you talking about a position?
No, I didn't discover any new positions
for sorting the mail, I think
I've figured them all out.
Challenge accepted.
You want me to send you a diagram
of all the different ones?
I'll tell you what you're missing.
Okay.
Watching trashy reality TV.
We've been here, I've done a couple,
I think I did a whole episode essentially
about "Married at First Sight".
And may be also, "90 Day Fiance".
Man, we love some trashy reality TV.
We love just...
We're watching "The
Bachelorette" right now,
which "The Bachelorette" is
almost not trashy enough for us.
It's almost too like respectable.
The people on "The Bachelorette",
the dudes on "The Bachelorette",
I mean, there's some that
they embarrass themselves
on a regular basis,
but they don't embarrass themselves enough
and to a degree, that is
pleasing enough to me personally.
Here's what I need when it
comes to trashy reality.
Okay.
I need people who just make
one bad decision after another.
Just like an avalanche of bad decisions.
Yeah.
And I need it.
I need it nonstop.
And I need to cut
from one person making
a really bad decision
to another person making
a really bad decision.
And then figuring out who
made the worst decision.
And I don't know what it says
about me, but first of all,
apparently this is the
case with many of y'all
because A, these shows tend
to be incredibly popular,
but every time I've talked about them,
the most response I ever get on Twitter
is people talking about these shows.
'Cause anyway,
Well, you realize you're doing it again.
my wife and I-
You're talking about the show,
you're not talking about whites,
you're not talking about you.
Well, no, I talked about whites
I'm just messing with you.
'cause it's people making
bad decisions, but anyway-
I just don't want the next 30 minutes
to be talking about "The Bachelorette".
Oh, okay.
Anyway, I can tell you some details.
But it is our little
time, in fact, tonight,
we're gonna watch an episode.
But we connect.
It's funny we're
connecting with each other,
we're both on our phones,
seeing what people said about
it when they watched it,
we're usually a little bit behind,
and we're also watching on the West Coast.
So, we're seeing the tweets
that people made about it
when they watched the East Coast feed.
And you don't have to
really pay attention.
And you know when you look up,
it's just gonna be somebody
making a bad decision
or saying something stupid.
And there's just something,
my wife and I have
bonded deeply over this.
My number six, in stark contrast,
due to your last entry is the
Black Lives Matter movement.
Okay.
So yeah, I'm making a hard turn here
into some meaningful and
potentially heavy waters.
It's such a pivotal point in history.
I actually still feel,
whenever I start to talk about
it, I get really hesitant
because I'm like, who
am I to talk about this?
Or to figure out what to say.
What if I say the wrong
thing or the right thing?
There's still that residual
thing that's happening.
But for me, it's learning
that you know what,
I'm engaged in this.
And this is not just something
that I can hold at arms
length, further away,
I need to look at these issues,
I need to become educated,
that's what this year was
in terms of me stopping
and paying more attention
to the movement.
And also, I just wanna give a shout out
to all the mythical beasts who,
we had a fundraiser early on,
and then there was lots of donations
made to a variety of charities
associated with Black
Lives Matter movement.
And it was extremely meaningful to me
to do something and to make up my mind
to be a force for good,
and to try my best to
figure out how I do that.
And whether that's as a
company or as an individual,
and as a family, I think it's...
And do I have it figured out?
And am I tooting any type of horn?
I certainly hope it doesn't seem like it.
But I would be remiss if I
didn't put it on the list
and say that...
I mean, it was a pivotal
moment for me personally
to have this level of interaction
with Black Lives Matter and
such an important movement.
And it also made my list in
a slightly different way.
But I'll wait to share
that when I get there.
But yeah, I think that...
Yeah, this was a year
to be clear,
these issues have been things
that we personally cared about
for quite a while, but
I think that there is,
sometimes when you're like, why?
Okay, step one is caring.
Admitting that there is a problem,
admitting that you might even be
a part of the problem, right?
Step two is doing something about it.
And part of that has been being a student.
Because again, like you said,
we're not the ones with the ideas,
we're in a position where
the things that we say,
the things that we commit to
are impactful and powerful,
that's a privilege.
And I think that this is a year
where being a student, reading books,
people who have looked at these issues,
black voices who have really
considered these things
in a way that we could never
consider them personally,
but being able to
appreciate that perspective
and learn from it, and
kind of be a student.
For me, this year kind
of represented going from
being concerned and feeling like,
yeah something needs to be done about this
to begin to listen to people
who have been saying that
and actually taking action for years,
and saying, okay, how can we be supportive
and be a part of that?
And I'll talk a little bit more
about a personal thing related to that.
What's your number five?
This is one of my
higher ones.
Number five is the all day live stream
that we did relatively recently.
I mean, there has been some dispute
over whether or not doing it
from 9:00 to 5:00 was all day,
but for us, that was all day .
But we didn't really know
what we were getting
ourselves into with this.
We did the live stream that
benefited Inner-City Arts,
a charity that we had been wanting
to partner with for a while
and had not really, given
the nature of this year,
been given an opportunity to do it.
And people, influencers,
or whatever you wanna say
doing charity live streams,
it's not a new thing,
but it was new for us.
And we were like, if we're gonna do this,
we wanna do it in a way that's effective
and actually makes a difference,
but we wanna do it in
a way that's mythical.
We wanna do it in a way
that is entertaining.
And our team did an incredible job
of pulling together the live stream.
And then the mythical
beasts did an incredible job
of showing up and giving.
We raised over $350,000
for Inner-City Arts.
Yeah, I was blown away.
And I will say, you know
what, we're in alignment,
this is my number five
Oh, wow.
as well.
Stars align.
I went home that night after
the live stream had ended
and I just was just processing.
And every way that I
looked at the experience,
if it was the work that
Inner-City Arts is doing
and how I could just feel...
I know what it feels like
to have to raise money
as part of a nonprofit.
And sometimes it feels very thankless.
So, I got great joy from
knowing how it must've felt
to the Inner-City Arts people
who dedicated their lives,
and at times you might feel
under-appreciated or forgotten,
to have that vote of confidence
from people all over the
world was tremendously moving.
Like you're saying, to look
at our team and to say how...
It was within the context of their job,
but I could tell that everyone involved
went above and beyond
and outside of the scope
of their normal work to give of themselves
to make this happen.
I got a lot of joy from that.
Seeing our kids get involved,
and calling our parents and
getting them involved in it
and making a decision to
bring back former employees
like Mike and Alex and Jen,
and have them show up and celebrate,
basically implied it like,
you guys have moved on
from working with us,
we're not employing you anymore,
but you're still doing great
things out there in the world,
and we still have this connection that...
It felt good to still be connected
and to bring them back in and
to have this extended family.
But ultimately to make a decision
that it was a family affair,
I saw that one of the
comments afterward was,
one mythical beast,
I'm sorry I can't remember
your handle specifically said,
"I love being a part of this family."
Because we decided we
weren't gonna bring in guests
and we weren't gonna make it one of those
telethon type things, which is great,
and we love being a part of that too,
but for it to be our thing
in partnership with Inner-City Arts
was something that I
think, just like I said,
and there's many more ways,
but every way I would
look at it from any angle,
it was just something
that brought a lot of joy
to invest in something in the arts.
Well, it was kinda
mythically coming full circle
because we're doing something
that we're having fun doing,
it's entertaining, there's a
lot of lighthearted moments
and fun moments,
but it's directly doing
something for good.
There's a lot of indirect good
that we hear comes from
the stuff that we do,
where it's like, oh, this
helped me get through
a difficult time or whatever,
and of course we do give to charity,
but to do something
that is so directly tied
to a course like that,
it felt really good.
That's why it was my number five too, man.
So, you're number four.
Number four, okay.
We went on a trip with
our boys, two of us,
and all four of our boys,
I got two, he's got two,
to Death Valley.
Did a multi-day camping trip.
And what we're gonna do,
this is my number four,
again, 'cause it was a great trip,
but we're gonna do a whole
episode where we talk about this.
So, I'm not gonna go into any details.
Well, I think we can kick
off at the top of the year.
Okay.
Let's devote it to...
This trip.
'Cause there's a handful of stories,
Things happened.
things that happened.
Things always happen, ever since.
Yeah, so it's like, we gotta
give you a whole episode
of our time in Death Valley with our boys.
So that can be the next episode.
Well, we're taking a break,
a holiday break,
and then we're coming back
at the top of the year.
As that can be the first in January.
So, did you put it on
your list or did you say
no, I would've said it?
Nope.
Didn't put it on my list.
But was it one of your
top 10 favorite things?
No.
Because it's not on my list.
I mean again-
Well, my number four, man.
The order...
Doesn't matter?
It could be on my list.
I mean, my trip to Joshua Tree
isn't on the list.
My beach trip isn't on the list,
but there's like, they should be.
Yeah. The list can only be so big.
My number four is
starting and doing the
listening party with Britney.
Yeah, that's my number three too.
No, it isn't.
It's not.
Britney lived with us all last year.
He made my top 10 last year.
And then he moved out,
and especially with
quarantine being shut down,
it's like, we didn't see each other.
And actually, we kind
of fell out of touch.
Didn't like each other any more.
Even though he lived, he's
just over there in Burbank,
he's not far away, but
we couldn't get together.
Right.
And so, one day I'm like, I
need to reconnect with him,
and we were talking
and I was like talking about how I missed,
we started talking about
music and I was like,
you know what?
I miss us talking about music.
That's what we would
stay up late at night,
just like standing around
in the kitchen just talking,
you know how he is.
You get him talking about music,
He'll keep talking.
three hours later,
you're still talking about music.
And we would just play
songs for each other.
He's an encyclopedia.
We play songs for each other
and I was like, you know what, let's...
And I'm just looking for things
that become connection
amidst this COVID thing.
And I wanted to reconnect and I'm like,
let's start making playlist,
let's collaborate on a playlist.
And that can be a way
that we can have a project
and we can be talking to each other.
And then we were like, screw it,
let's do it on Instagram.
If John Mayer can have an Instagram live,
Yeah, anybody can.
and that almost made the list,
me and Lilly watching "Current Mood"
where we were obsessed with
that until he stopped doing it.
Yeah. It became an
obligation for him too .
I was like, we can do that.
So, we made it a live stream,
but it was very much about
the two of us connecting,
and anybody who wanted
to share on that music,
they could do it, and
still can on my Instagram.
But it was a very special time for us,
'cause we would talk throughout the week
and get a kick out of
building this playlist.
And then we would experience it together
on this live stream.
And especially early on,
it was just an opportunity
for us to process,
many times, the emotions of
going through quarantine.
And because music is so
important to both of us,
there's this really experience in
the soul connection
that music can provide.
Connecting to your own soul,
but then also connecting to somebody else.
And I mean, it bonded us at
a time when our relationship
could have moved further apart.
I find it interesting that at this point,
the way that I approach things,
I started to approach it very like,
okay, well, this is how we gotta do it,
and this is what it's about.
And I started making it
about the wrong things.
And I was like, hey, I need
to take a break from this
because things are getting
busy here at work again.
So, for like November,
we took a break from it.
Because it started becoming
about something else
and about an obligation to somebody
besides just me and Britney hanging out.
Yeah, things don't have
to last forever, man.
Things don't have to last forever.
There were a handful of lifelines
that have gotten me through,
and that was certainly one of them.
And will always be very special to me.
And I know, to him too.
We had a lot of big laughs too.
You know those big laughs?
The laughs that come in the midst of
when you just feel like crap.
I mean, there's few
things more therapeutic.
Maybe there's nothing more
therapeutic than a good laugh
at the right time when you really need it.
And so, that's what a listening party.
That's the soul of that for me.
And that's my number four.
My number three is related
to the Black Lives Matter movement.
And when everything was happening
and specifically kind of the catalyst that
just brought this issue
to the forefront again
was the murder of George Floyd, right?
And there's been a few times
when I've written something on,
I'll write a medium
article about something,
and usually the thing
that gets me to the point
where I feel like I have something to say
or there's something I have
to say that I can't not say
is when I just see people
saying things online
and I'm just like, I kinda feel
like I can speak into this.
And I get something in
my mind and my heart
and I just have to say it, I
have to just get it out, right?
When everything was coming out,
most people who have a
senior sort of public persona
were acknowledging the
movement in some way, right?
And for the same reasons
that you were pointing out
in the beginning, it's just like,
well, it seems to me that a lot of times,
I'm not speaking for all white guys,
but it tends to be kind
of a white guy thing
to be like, well, I've
got something to say
and you should listen to me, right?
Anybody can do it, but we
have a pretty bad track record
of believing that whatever we have to say
is the most important thing to say.
And so, I was sensitive to that,
knowing that I don't
bring a lot of education
and a lot of personal
experience and perspective
into this issue.
So again, I was like, I want to listen,
but I also want to be a responsible ally.
And it hit me that the way
that I could be involved was,
I saw a lot of people saying things
related to the incident with George Floyd
that sort of reflected some
things that I might have said
in my past that are kind of
based on where I come from
and the mentality that I had growing up,
and kind of the lack of experience
and lack of knowledge that I had,
and lack of empathy, frankly,
that I had for people
outside of my own experience.
And so, that's when I wrote what I call
"Letter to a White Man",
which was essentially writing
a letter to the old RET
and saying, "Hey, listen, I
know that you actually do care
about these things,
but a lot of the things
that you think and say
and the way that you react to these things
are contributing to the problem,
they're not actually solving the problem."
So, I wrote that kind of
self-conscious about it again,
because it was ironically a
white dude saying something.
But again, I was a white
dude saying something
to a white dude,
and my former self to be specific.
And the thing that was
really encouraging about it
was the response.
I mean, sure, a lot of
people were upset with me,
pointed out all the
things that they thought,
all the places where I was wrong
but there were a number of
people who communicated,
whether it be through
like an Instagram message
or something on Twitter,
who said, "Hey, this was
legitimately impacted me.
Because a lot of the things that you said
are the things that I have
been thinking about this,
and it actually gave me a
chance to reflect on that
and to consider a different perspective."
And just one person saying
that would have been worth it.
But the reaction was super positive.
For me, I wasn't doing it for attention,
and I wasn't doing it to
get a pat on the back,
I was doing it simply because I know
there was a lot of people
out there like me, right?
And I thought I had
something to say to me.
And the fact that-
And to hear from some people
Yeah.
like that,
that was your aim.
Yeah.
So, that was super, super encouraging.
So, I bet that felt good.
'Cause it's the same reason
that the live stream is on the list.
Because it's
realizing that we do have a platform.
And again, that pervasive question of,
what's the right thing to do
with this opportunity that we have?
And you've got things that you wanna say,
it can be a treacherous path to figure out
how to take a stand on issues
or how to make a difference.
And you can be intimidated
into doing nothing,
even within your own mind,
not by anyone else, even.
So, I mean that's something that
been inspired by with the
Black Lives Matter Movement,
is that you can find
a way to do something.
And yeah, I'm super
proud of what you wrote,
and how you went about it.
And it's also not on my list.
Well, thanks.
My number three is a painful one,
I might cry, I don't know
exactly what I'm gonna say,
so I just feel emotional about it.
But I wanted to put this on the list again
because it was an impactful
moment for me this year.
And maybe there's a silver lining to it,
but it's just something
that I haven't talked about,
but was a defining moment in my 2020.
And that is that when my grandma,
who I've always called my nanny,
my mom's mom, passed away.
She passed away in June
and I couldn't go home.
Right.
And it hurt a lot.
And it still hurts.
It wasn't a surprise,
it didn't happen quickly,
and in some ways, that made
it much more difficult.
I was looking back at my Evernotes,
which sometimes they're dated,
but it's definitely not a journal,
of my record of my memories
from Thanksgiving last year.
And I was like,
who was here this Thanksgiving
and is not gonna be
here next Thanksgiving?
And I was thinking about nanny,
when you go and visit her,
and I think I talked
about that experience.
Every year you go home as
your grandparents get older,
it's like, maybe this is the
last year I'm spending with her
and living in California.
Maybe this is the last time
I'm seeing her in person.
Right.
Was that Thanksgiving.
And it turns out that it was in.
So, it is nice to have that awareness
and to have those memories of,
this may be it so I'm
going to acknowledge that.
And so, I'm grateful for that.
The last time I saw her in person was,
there was kind of an understanding
that that might be it.
I will say that it was that way
for a couple of years, actually.
And she was at home,
and they brought an hospice,
she was made comfortable as she passed.
And that was about a week and a half.
And it was excruciatingly
difficult to come to grips
with the fact that the right decision
was not to fly home at that time.
It wasn't simply just the COVID of it all,
I mean, there were a number of factors
which impacted my immediate family.
I'll just say that
the accumulation of all the factors
led to it being the right decision,
but it's like, there's still
this doubt in your mind
just like, should I go home or not?
And it's like, it never felt great.
It still doesn't feel great.
In some ways, it doesn't feel real,
still having not been home,
I haven't had the experience
of going back in the house
and her not being there.
I know a lot of people...
She didn't have COVID,
just as a side note,
but I know a lot of people
have lost a lot of loved ones
and it has been extremely painful
to not be able to see them
as they're passing.
But they're right there.
I was across the country
and it was excruciating.
So, my heart goes out to all those people
who are on the other
side of a pane of glass,
having to watch someone pass.
I knew that I would have
spoken at her funeral.
And when she was planning her funeral,
she was telling her sisters
what she wanted to wear,
and she said,
"I want Link to sing a
song at the funeral."
And I don't think she quite understood
that I wasn't gonna be able to be there.
And so, it broke my heart to know that
I couldn't deliver on that.
But I wrote a eulogy
and I emailed it to the to the pastor
who was already speaking,
to read at the funeral.
And I had mailed them
the record that we made
for the Mythical Society
where we covered "Silver
Wings", the Merle Haggard song.
And I knew it was my aunt, Vickie,
who, for basically her entire adult life,
lived with my nanny.
Oldest sister, youngest
sister lived together.
Even when my papa was alive,
aunt Vicki still lived there.
And then when he passed, it
was just the two of them.
And now it's just aunt Vicki,
and she has another sister
that she's close with
and spends a lot of time
with, thank goodness.
But I mailed them the record
because it was her favorite song
but then that was the solution.
They actually played our-
Yeah, they played our
rendition of "Silver Wings"
at the funeral service.
And then they read my eulogy.
But it was just tough not to be there.
So, there's a lot of
pain associated with it
and a lack of closure.
I think until I can get back home again,
I think it'll still kind of be in,
the wound will be a little
more open than I would help.
It's my number three
because it's such a poignant milestone,
I don't know how it's changed me,
but you can just feel that like, okay,
this is one of those things
that shapes you as a person
when you go through something,
when it's so frustrating and so painful
to not be able to be
there for your family.
Well, it's not on my list.
But thanks for sharing.
I have one that probably is on your list.
And that is my number two.
Us telling our stories the last
years on this very podcast,
which I guess we did in January, February?
We did it...
Yup, I mean, in January, the
first two episodes came out
and then in February
And then February.
is when your deconstruction
story came out then mine.
So, it's January
Yeah, 'cause we kind of
to February.
toggle back on everything.
And this is my number two as well.
Okay, we sync up again.
So,
we're syncing up once again.
I don't think, boy, what a weird year,
what a very, very weird year
that this happened this year
and then COVID happened.
But-
I think we had decided
we were gonna do this
At the end of 2019.
October or November of 2019.
Yeah. Yeah.
And so, we had the sense
that it was gonna be like,
we're doing it early in 2020,
but it was gonna be something
that would maybe reshape
the course of "Ear Biscuits"
or we didn't know it would lead to.
I was antsy to tell the story, right?
And I think that for me,
it had been kind of a long time coming.
And one of the reasons I wanted
to kind of tell our story
is because our background
of growing up as Christians,
not just Christians but
evangelical Christians
it was the center piece of our life,
and then the centerpiece of
our career in the early days.
There was so much tension in
being vulnerable and personal,
and talking about our lives,
mostly in this medium of "Ear Biscuits",
but we talk about ourselves all the time.
We're constantly kind of
telling the stories and stuff,
and to have this giant piece of your past
that informs who you are
and constantly finding
ways to gloss over it,
there were so many tangential things
about our career and the
path that we're at right now,
and the fact that we worked
with campus crusade for a while
and it's kind of the reason
that we got into comedy,
all these things that
we weren't able to say,
to me, there was always
this like kind of shame
associated with our past,
but also a shame of not
being honest about it
that had just created this tension.
For me, telling the story
and kind of just saying, here
it is, without any apologies,
we're just gonna tell you the whole story
of where we were and where we
are now and how we got here,
to me, it opened something
up within me, right?
The way that I think about
the things that we talk
about on this podcast now
has kind of changed pretty
dramatically for me.
It's like, if there's something
that comes up and it's...
We would avoid anything
that got into spirituality
at all, right?
If it was just like, well,
this kind of gets into talking
about God or religion
or faith or whatever,
we would avoid it.
And it's so strange for people who,
that is such a big part of who we are,
to not be able to talk about it.
I'm not even really gonna get into the...
I mean, the response was overwhelming
in every sense of the word,
both positive and negative,
and the way that it kind of
transformed people's perspective
of us, both for the good and for the bad,
we gained fans, we lost fans.
But really it was so impactful for me
'cause I just felt like it was this,
ironically, is the way that you describe
becoming a Christian a lot of times,
as a huge burden is lifted off of you.
And you have this feeling,
this sense of relief
when you give your life to God.
Ironically for me, kind
of talking about how
I'm in a completely different place
and no longer consider myself a Christian
or a person of faith in
that way specifically,
was a huge burden that
was lifted off of me.
I think for me, it was a
milestone in my spiritual journey
because in a lot of ways,
it said, okay, now I can...
Not that I couldn't move forward
or I needed to talk about
it in order to move forward,
but it kind of was that.
I don't know, it was like,
okay, I can document what
brought me to this point
in my spiritual journey, the
exercise of talking about it
and the preparation leading to that
really helped me make
sense of it for myself
so that now I can...
It made it so I could move forward
in a way that I don't think I could
because I hadn't processed it enough.
I mean, I definitely really began
to appreciate my relationship with guilt.
And this was the year
that I started therapy,
and I'm continuing my spiritual journey.
And a journey of openness
and self discovery
as part of that too.
But I'm moving forward in openness,
and I'm also saying, all right,
I'm still coming to grips
with, what is my relationship to guilt?
In addition to what is
my relationship to God
and to belief and expectations
as a human or as a father or a husband.
So again, these are all things
that I'm still very much in process.
I mean, who's not in process?
But I do feel like it
released me in some ways,
and then gave me a trajectory
to continue to move forward.
So, it's not about a label,
it's not about coming to a
conclusion or a new affiliation
or an allegiance to some other system,
religious or otherwise,
but there's momentum.
I do find it interesting that like,
I still don't know where...
Talk about momentum,
COVID really kinda
truncated the experience.
We put these things out there,
there was a lot of response,
I had to go on a hike and clear my head
and figure out how to
deal with the fact that
so many people, it turns out,
really cared about the fact
that we talked about this.
And they all didn't agree with us.
But then COVID hit and it
kind of, in a lot of ways,
it felt like it didn't happen.
I had to get reacquainted
with the fact that like,
remember January, February,
this big milestone moment happened.
And number two on our list.
It seems like ages ago, I had
to get reacquainted with it.
We had specifically, we
had done an interview
for a major publication that
is related to Christian faith,
that never was published
because COVID hit.
And then we were featured
in another publication.
Two pretty popular Christian publications
were gonna do stories on this thing.
And it just never happened.
And the people who were talking about it
had a whole lot of other
stuff to talk about.
And maybe that was a blessing in disguise.
I mean, again, one of the few times
that I've written something in our medium
was in response to the responses
that we were processing at the time,
the four of us, the two
of us and our wives.
I have absolutely no regrets.
Obviously, you always wish
you might've said something
a little bit differently,
'cause that's just the way it goes
when you decide to talk about something,
but the decision to share that story
is something that I am just
incredibly grateful for.
It was a coming out.
It really was.
Yeah, 100%.
It was so difficult to be a certain person
and to be so open about so many things,
but not be open about
something that's so core
to who you are.
Yeah.
And that's why I think
using that terminology is applicable.
I'm not gonna say it's to the same degree
or the same experience as somebody
who's coming out of the closet would have,
but like I can relate
at least a little bit.
And it's because this is who I am.
And I don't wanna be
ashamed or scared about it.
I mean, that at its core, is that relief.
Because it's like, hey, I'm
just being and openly sharing
who I am.
Take it as you will.
Throughout our career,
we've been people
pleasers in a lot of ways.
It's like, we're pretty
tame, we're pretty safe.
There's a lot of people from
a lot of different backgrounds
that enjoy the things that we do.
And we have a pretty
broad appeal by design.
We want things to be accessible
and we want it to be a break.
We don't want it to be affiliated
with any particular view.
We're just hey, just take a load off
and come enjoy this thing that we made.
But we didn't really take a stand
as much as we just told our story,
but it was interpreted as taking
a stand by a lot of people.
And I don't think we've ever experienced
that level of scrutiny and criticism.
And that was something that
was very difficult at the time.
But again, as someone who struggles with
and places too much value on
other people's opinions of me,
it's good to have those opinions
be very, very loud and negative
so that you can detach a little bit more
from those expectations.
Which kind of leads me into number one.
Okay, we're two on number ones.
Which I think, in some ways was,
at least as 2020, as concerned,
kind of a culmination of just
kind of what you were getting at,
which the beginning of,
sort of the next stage
of what spirituality is to me.
And I did a whole podcast on it.
So, I'm not gonna go
into too many details,
but it was my solo trip that
I took earlier in the year.
And again, there were details
of things that happened to me
sort of just things
that I kind of realized
or came to grips with, whatever
the word you wanna use is,
that I'm not going to share
because I feel like it was for me,
and I'm not trying to make it for you.
But I think that it's very much tied
to the fact that we told our stories
because there was a little
bit of stagnation, right?
Because there's this like,
I've left this thing and I
don't know what I'm going to,
but I don't want to jump
into some other kind of
fundamentalism, right?
I don't wanna jump from
one fundamentalism,
from one ideological rut to another.
Is just something that I was
trying really hard not to do.
And it's very difficult to do that.
It's very difficult to
maintain sort of an openness
and an openness to spirituality in general
when you kind of feel like
you've sort of been duped in a way,
but my trip which is something
that I had been trying to organize,
it's difficult, especially this year
to sort of logistically organize going off
when you're a father,
husband, and business owner
for, I think it ended up being like
six days and five nights.
But right from the beginning,
it was just such a rich experience.
And I haven't even totally processed it.
There was a lot of journal
writing, speaking of journal,
and it wasn't just Evernote,
it was a literal physical
journal in a literal space pen.
You should take a picture of the pages
in case you lose it.
I've thought about that.
In fact, just the other day,
I was like, where is that journal?
And I was like,
I can't find my journal.
It was in my backpack.
Scan it.
Or my book bag, as you say.
I think it is going to be the beginning
of a tradition for me.
Probably annual, I don't know.
I hope, at least annual.
I actually reinvested,
I put some money into my truck.
Since that camping
trip, I've got a drawer.
You saw my drawer.
I see.
Yeah you got a drawer.
A drawer installed
in my FJ that makes camping,
like, you can be ready to go.
I could go tonight if I wanted
to, installed in the drawer.
Got everything in a drawer.
And just the value of escape,
solitude, personal reflection,
and just understanding that,
man, this isn't just me,
this is everybody.
Everybody got their own shit
that they got to deal with
on a daily basis.
And the responsibilities and the busyness,
and the distractions and all the things
that keep you from really
checking in with yourself.
And checking in with
yourself in a meaningful way,
in an intentional way that's
designed to kind of like,
hey, let's keep this train
going in our direction,
in the right direction,
whatever you wanna call it.
And yeah, it was-
Yeah, it's easy to forget
that your life is yours alone,
ultimately.
Yeah.
Again, this is the case for everybody.
I think that you can really
begin to over identify
not only with your opinions and positions,
I could fall into opinions and arguments
and that kind of thing,
but you can also over identify
with your different stations in life.
Now, first of all, if you're
a father, if you're a husband,
if you're a boss,
Sure.
you should lean into that
and be the best that you can.
But when you are only those things,
and you only exist in
relationship to other people
or as what you can be for someone else,
which is, listen, hey,
you wanna be selfless
and you wanna be a
servant of other people,
but sometimes you can get lost,
you can lose yourself in that.
You can also get lost
in your own personality.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, and to me, it was like,
taking that solo trip was,
you got your own stink that
you're carrying around with you.
Your own stink, right?
I just call it my own bullshit, right?
In fact, just last night I
told Jessie before therapy,
'cause my therapy was kind of scheduled
for a different night than
it was because of our trip
to Death Valley.
We had a pretty difficult
day business-wise yesterday
in terms of just dealing
with a lot of things
all at once and sort of being a boss
was demanding yesterday, right?
And I got home and I was just like,
man, I don't wanna go to therapy tonight.
I know I'm going to, I just don't want to.
'Cause I told you, I was just like,
sometimes you just don't wanna
deal with your own bullshit.
Because that's what therapy is, right?
But for me, that's what the solo trip was.
It was like, all right, I've stripped away
all my responsibilities and relationships,
and here I am sitting alone,
oh, there it is, there's
my big bag of bullshit.
Let's start unpacking it a little bit.
And it was good.
I mean, it turns out it stinks pretty bad.
But I think I left-
Well, you were in a hot spring too.
I did leave some of the bullshit
and some of the hot springs.
Okay.
So, that's my number one.
And I hope that I can do it again.
My number one is,
if I were to translate my psyche
and my emotional well-being
to a physical location,
it will be my garage.
So, my number one
is the fact that I have
my garage remodeled.
And then I reorganized all of
it in a wonderful cabinetry.
And listen, as a person
who only saw your garage
before and after, I can
say it's a thing of beauty.
Oh yeah, I got to post
one of those pictures
on Instagram, the swipes.
Actually kinda,
the thing I was thinking
about is your garage
is so well-organized that it
sort of feels like an Ikea.
It sort of feels like something
needs to be misplaced here,
like a sock or something.
Or like an oil stain or
something needs to happen.
Because right now
It feels so good.
it feels like a showroom.
I just go out there and stand.
Yeah, I mean, I'm saying it's so good,
it's a little impersonal.
All right, that's not my number one.
I mean, Christie was like,
I was telling her the list
last night and she was like,
"You didn't put your garage on the list?"
They give me such a hard time.
Once everything was organized,
I gave each member of the house
their own personalized tour of it.
What?
I took each person out there
and I gave them a tour of it.
I was so proud.
They didn't seem to care.
Christie cared some
because she helped do the
redesign of some of it.
But no, I didn't put that in my top 10,
that's just an honorable mention.
My number one is,
same time you were on your solo trip,
I was on my solo trip with my wife.
Okay, so you're just
trying to make me look bad.
No .
I see what's going on.
The van trip, I didn't do a solo trip,
but I need to do one.
I mean, I think I got a bag of bullshit.
I mean, I probably do.
I don't know, maybe you've
been filling up my bag.
Anyway .
I don't know what you're saying.
No, I wanna do that,
but for reasons I'll
get into a little bit,
Christie and I really needed this trip.
And when I talked about it before
in the podcast where I talked about it,
Christie pointed out
after listening to it,
she was like, "You didn't say
that that was our 20th
wedding anniversary."
And I was like, well, that's because...
Well, I didn't say anything,
but I was like, okay.
In her mind, and I guess for both of us,
we had to cancel our wedding anniversary.
We were gonna go to Big Sur.
I thought I did mention
that, she says I didn't,
but, I mean, we were due for that
to be able to celebrate 20
years of being together.
But as I described, we went to Utah
and one of the hikes we
took was in Bryce Canyon,
which is this beautiful place
that has all these mud hoodoos
that you walk through.
And we walked around
one corner-
Is that a technical term.
Are we having a conversation
we've already had?
A hoodoo, I don't know,
we talked about it.
Yes, a technical term,
that's what they call them.
We walked around this one corner,
and I saw a piece of paper on the ground.
I was like, oh somebody littered.
There's four rocks on
it, holding it in place,
and it is a letter to
people along the trail.
Now, technically, you shouldn't do this.
You shouldn't be writing letters
and leaving them on a trail.
But-
'Cause what if everybody did that?
Then there'd be letters all over the place
and it would just be
Littered.
It would be wrecked.
It wouldn't be a letter,
it would be litter.
Only one person left a letter,
and I took a picture of it.
I didn't even read the whole thing.
But I would like to read it now.
I didn't share this in
the previous podcast.
And then through the lens of this letter,
I can unpack why the van
trip was my number one.
I will say, and I've
got sort of a side view
of your screen here,
Yeah.
I have not been able to
interpret what that is.
From my angle, which I'm
just kind of seeing the side,
it looked like there was
some crazy stationary,
like do you know how
you can get stationary
that has a like border,
and then has like lines that somebody
on?
Oh, you thought
that the dirt
around the paper was part-
I thought this was all
like a printed thing that you
would get at like a wedding.
But no, it's just a picture
you took of a letter on dirt.
Yeah, handwritten letter
displaced under some rocks,
the breeze wouldn't blow it away.
"Hello, if you're reading this,
you made it to a beautiful place on earth.
Oh, the importance of roaming.
I will say the one thing
quarantine has taught us
is to free our minds.
They are meant to wander and
you are meant to be here.
I am so happy to be in this canyon.
For a few years, I've been
battling lupus and fibromyalgia.
It can be very devastating to
experience at 26 years old,
but I realized everyone is
fighting a personal battle.
Maybe you're out here to
escape or start a new journey,
whatever it may be, it has purpose
and you are worthy of self discovery."
The letter continues, but I'll stop there.
I don't wanna get into too
many details about the summer
that our family went through
because a lot of it is
Christie's story to tell
and not mine,
but it definitely rings true
that everyone is fighting
a personal battle.
And there was a personal battle
that was going on in our home.
Christie was struck with a
debilitating level of anxiety
associated with physical symptoms
that she was having in the midst of COVID.
We hear anecdotal
evidence of so many people
struggling internally,
mentally and emotionally
within the context of COVID
and quarantine, isolation,
health anxiety, the list goes on
and impacts people in
so many different ways.
But for Christie and for us as a couple,
and then as a family,
I would say there was a
couple of pockets of time,
and you know what I'm talking about, where
it was extremely difficult
for her and for us
to face together.
It was something that we faced together,
but I would say it was
probably the most challenging
concentration of struggle
that we had to walk through
in our 20 years of marriage.
It was a scary time for her and for us.
And I know we talked about it and
you were tremendously
helpful in that time,
and I wanna thank you again for that.
And again, it's not a
story that I wanna tell,
but that was our personal
battle that we were fighting.
And there were times when
I could do nothing else
except engage in being
there with her through that.
And it was, I can't do anything else.
I can't be present for work.
It was unlike anything
I'd ever experienced.
And at times it was very confusing and
scary, I'll just say.
But now, I can speak from the
other side of it and say that
I think this letter really
rings true to our experience
in that, I mean, she has
lupus and fibromyalgia
and says it can be very
devastating to experience that,
but she realized that everyone
is fighting a personal battle
and that everybody's on their own journey.
And whatever it may be, it has a purpose,
and you are worthy of self discovery.
And I do think that
that was our experience
walking through the trials
that we went through
over the summer in terms of finding out
what we were really made of
as individuals and as a
couple and as a family.
So, going on this trip,
it was much more than just rescheduling
a celebration of our anniversary.
It was being together.
If you rerun everything that
I described from that trip
through the lens of the trials
that we had been through
that I know I'm not
sharing the details of,
that's the level of meaning
that puts this at number one for me,
because we needed it so badly,
to have an experience together
where we could focus on each other.
And it was very special,
until we were almost killed by a guy
Yeah, by .
who wanted to buy
hot dogs from us.
You were almost killed,
which I think getting away from a murderer
Yeah.
is actually,
that's like a number one.
also puts things in perspective.
It's been a difficult
year for so many people,
and it's on a global scale.
And so, to be able to
look back on our years
and to pull together 10 and
have some honorable mentions,
and to have made it through this year,
I mean, it ain't over and
who knows what 2021 holds,
but having gone through 2020,
I feel like I'm a better person for it .
And I'm not inviting
more trials in 2021, but
I think that I'm more grateful
having experienced this year.
And my heart goes out to the people
who are still in dire straits,
and they're in the thick of it.
So, I don't have answers,
but I have empathy.
And if you're going through something
and it's a comfort to you,
I'll just pass along what
the letter had to say again,
that whatever it may be, it has purpose,
and you are worthy of self discovery.
Yeah, it has been such a difficult year.
And like you said, it
continues to be very difficult.
I think there is some light
at the end of the tunnel
at this point, but there's
gonna be scars on families
and on people's psyches,
from just going through what
they've gone through this year.
People's livelihoods, businesses,
there's been so many challenges.
Sometimes, I sort of imagine what,
you know how when you're
sick with just like a cold,
not anything like COVID, but just a cold,
and you can't breathe out of your nose?
And you think to yourself,
man, when I can breathe in my nose again,
I'm not gonna take it for granted.
I'm gonna smell so hard.
I'm gonna think about every breath .
And then as soon as you can
breathe through your nose again,
most time you don't even realize
that you can breathe
through your nose again,
you just go on about your business
and breathe in through your nose
like some professional athlete breather,
taking it for granted.
I think about what life is gonna be like.
I think about being able
to just go to a restaurant
without thinking about...
I'm not going to any
restaurants right now,
but going out and not having
to think about everything you're touching
and how close you're getting to people,
and whether you got a mask on,
and just living life again,
being able to hug somebody
without thinking about it,
being able to gather with people again.
Man, I hope I never take
that stuff for granted again.
You might have had the privilege
of knowing somebody who
lived through the depression,
would be a very old person at this point,
but my wife's grandmother
who died in her 90s recently
had some memories of that time
and kinda came up in sort
of an age of scarcity.
And she would use
aluminum foil or tinfoil,
as she would call it,
she put it on a dish and then
she would take it off the dish
and she would roll it back
up and put it in the drawer.
And she was frugal and she
saved and she conserved.
And it was because she had that mentality.
I wonder sometimes, are
we gonna carry that?
Can we get to the other side of the tunnel
and not take for granted the things
that we've been missing,
and just the the struggles that people,
when we get through this
collectively as a species,
'cause like you said,
this is a global thing.
Well, you know what?
I think it's up to us.
Yeah.
And I think this exercise,
again, I cherish it every year,
but I think it's all that
more important this year
for that reason.
So it's, hey, this happened,
but these other things happened too.
Yeah.
There's things
to be grateful for and I can be grateful
for the trials and the
pain associated with it too
in due time.
And I'm thankful for this,
And over time.
you talked about the family
and we have a family here at Mythical,
but this is a family thing, what we have,
and you listening to this.
I think so many people have...
We've been humbled the many
times that we've met people
in person, back when we used to tour,
but also just seeing
people say things online
about the stupid stuff that we do,
and the serious stuff that we talk about,
how this has been meaningful for people.
And I think about that with
the things that entertain me.
This has been such a difficult time
that the connections that you
can make with people online
in the outlets that entertain you,
I like to think of this as,
we're not just here to
entertain you, but this is,
we're having this ongoing
discussion as a family.
So, thank you for those of you
who have stuck with us through 2020,
and who have joined us in 2020
and you're a part of this Mythical herd.
And yeah, we're honored that
we have a place at your table
so to speak, that we're
part of your experience
and that we've been a part of your 2020,
and a part of your silver lining.
We're honored.
Of course.
Just like every "Ear Biscuit",
we end with a recommendation.
And my recommendation, as
this year comes to a close,
as this season of "Ear
Biscuits" comes to a close,
you know what?
Just relax.
That's my recommendation.
Just take the pressure off of yourself,
relax, reward yourself, do
something that you enjoy
for the sake of enjoyment.
You're gonna get through this year,
you're gonna get through this time,
and we will see you in the new year
with a new "Ear Biscuit".
That's right.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits",
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon
to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.